your uh country presently due to come
out of
your uh 17-day fire break
on the 9th of november given what we've
heard from our prime minister over the
weekend would you consider extending
that further
we won't be extending it we will be
coming out of our fire break on
the 9th of november that was the deal we
struck with people in wales
but if we went early and we had a very
sharp lockdown period because these 17
days
we've really asked people in wales to
live with extraordinary restrictions
but by going early and by having a short
but sharp
set of uh fire breaks we are confident
that we will come out on the 9th of
november
how frustrating is it for you to see the
furlough scheme extended now when
the chancellor was reluctant to do it
when you asked
well that was the main thing for me to
say is i'm always glad for any
extra help for businesses here in wales
and the extension of the furlough scheme
will help welsh businesses so
my main message is is to be glad that
that is happening it is frustrating that
when we ask
the chancellor for some flexibility in
his schemes
as we went into the fire break period he
told us that that wasn't possible
but when the prime minister decides to
do it for england lo and behold it turns
out to be possible
after all that will strike people in
wales as not being
fair the treasury is meant to be the
treasury for the whole of the united
kingdom
not just one part of it i wonder what
that might mean
for um future calls for an independence
for wales
well what i say to people who make that
argument is is that we
have a huge degree of independence
already we make our own laws here
in our senate we exercise the powers we
have
independently as we have throughout the
crisis when i have thought it
was right to do things for wales as we
did with our early fire break period
we went ahead and made that independent
decision
but at the same time we are able to draw
on
the strength of the united kingdom we
wouldn't be talking about
millions of extra uh pounds of money for
welsh
businesses if it wasn't for the fact
that we are part of
that big insurance policy that is the
united kingdom
paying in when we can drawing out when
we need it
i think wales has the best of both
worlds a strong and assertive devolution
settlement and membership of what i want
to see as a successful united kingdom
you must be frustrated though um i was
chatting to andy burnham uh
in earlier on in this hour actually mr
eckford and and he was basically saying
the north feels like there's
second-class citizens
to what's happening in westminster do
the people of wales feel the same
well what i think i've been frustrated
about is the fact that we have not had
throughout the coronavirus period a
sufficiently regular and reliable
pattern of engagement with the uk
government
we've the last cobra meeting we had is
nearly three weeks ago
i asked then for another meeting to
discuss sage's advice about a fire break
period
the first minister of scotland wrote
immediately to support that call
yet three weeks have gone by without a
meeting of that sort happening
that's my frustration that the uk
government in whose hands this
lies have not acted to bring us together
around the table to share information
have those discussions make better
decisions
with the reliability of the regularity
that i think would have
led to a stronger set of understanding
and a stronger set of decisions
that has been frustrating and remains so
how effective has the fire break been i
know there's another week or so
to go eight days to go but um have you
got any indication of how effective it's
been
well we've only got very early
indications we won't know whether the r
number has come down as we wished it to
be we won't know whether we've stemmed
the flow of people into hospitals
for a week or two after the fire break
ends but we do have
early figures of travel in wales
and they are encouraging there's a real
drop off in travel
and that demonstrates that people in
wales are abiding by the fire break
rules
they are staying at home they are
working from home they are avoiding
contact with other people
and that's how we will need people to go
on behaving
after the fire break is over asking each
other
not what can i do how far can i stretch
the rules
but what should i be doing how can i
make my contribution
to keeping myself and others safe by
minimizing contact with other people
working from home wherever possible
doing all the things we know
that help to keep one another safe from
what is still
a deadly virus